hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I am John Humphrey we are testing out
these microphones today for this special
video podcast we are going to do if the
mics don't work we have a backup mic so
let's hope these microphones are working
or enjoy these eyesores yeah I mean we
could put we can readjust it but I feel
like limited in movement need a box like
right in front of your chest just move
around as much as we want
now this podcast podcast audio just
talked super deep so one of our top
award tiers on patreon is that mics
whatever having different it makes you
feel different to have a microphone yeah
and one of our top reward tiers on
patreon is whatever video you request we
must definitely do and put up on YouTube
and today comes from a man named Michael
B who has a YouTube channel called Omni
one media and he has a great request
here which John and I have not made any
notes for we were just hoping the
microphones would give us you know the
energy to riff you know new toys all you
need to be inspired
why-why-why I make notes in prep when
you have microphones there's just gaiety
Andrea and I'm yelling at the mic it's
weird
beards weird so yeah his question two
minutes into this is so for the topic
with Game of Thrones coming to an end
and the spin-offs being announced in the
works what do you think a network or
studio should let something end rather
than continue to milk it examples
Breaking Bad Harry Potter Star Wars when
do you feel like it's earned or
necessary verse just abusing versing
just abusing it well I mean the the for
me the one little note that sort of
popped into my mind when I was thinking
about
this question as I sound important
talking into the microphone half of this
podcast is gonna be about us having a
microphone great it feels how new it is
I
I feel like a main issue that happens
with franchises especially with the
corporate world that we have in the
entertainment industry is we don't know
how to end things on a high note we we
have this thing where we if it keeps
making money we're just gonna keep
making more of them it's that's plain
and simple and if they start to lose
profit well how much profit did it lose
could we just you know bring down the
budget a little bit and then make
another one you know like with the
pirates movies they want to reboot them
like for me that's a scenario where I'm
like you should just let that end at
least for a while don't just reboot it
right now let it end for long enough
that when you really decide to reboot it
we're like oh yeah pirates I haven't
thought about know why or like Oh Johnny
Depp is definitely way too old to do
that now oh oh this is a nice test see
there's a there's a car horn honking
outside and normally when we have just
the directional mic we're filming off of
it's a real bother I mean it's still
distracting to us but hopefully the
microphones aren't picking it up yes
you'll only get it from the top man yeah
yeah and I don't think we're using that
top mic yeah any luck you won't know at
home other than the fact that we pointed
so yeah I think I think the thing is
like there are better examples I think
of truly ending on a high note
like I think the Dark Knight trilogy
comes to mind despite what you might
think of the Dark Knight Rises one thing
I really admire about the way that was
handled it was know what's done it's
over
sure Dark Knight Rises made well over a
billion dollars it was a very successful
film they could make more it's not like
they're low on Batman villains it's not
like Christian Bale is too old
even now I'm like
I still do it they could have continued
it but that was a good example of
putting your foot down and going no I
told the story I wanted to tell and I
feel like a lot of the times with these
franchises we just we we overly milk
them and sometimes it's not a bother you
know I feel like you can keep like the
Bond franchise seems to be one that
every time you think it's dead they come
out with a new one that's just like oh
that was excellent
yes when I feel like part of the allure
of bond in a weird way is the fact that
it is such a vast franchise are so many
stories and so many different iterations
of the character and that's something
too that you don't get as often is like
oh we're gonna recast him and that keeps
it right you know but then you know I
think for me I think expansion in
different mediums is a little cooler
than you know just like if we were
announced more Lord of the Rings movies
I'd be like just stop this with the
Hobbit yeah let it end you know just let
it end but I think an exploration of
more of middle-earth and you know the
additional stories to sort of riff off
of that j.r.r tolkien put down or even
with the Hobbit I admired the the effort
to include characters that weren't in
The Hobbit or you know develop new
characters I liked that
in in the yeah the concept of it more
than I did the execution so I think with
a TV show that gets me excited
especially with how TV and streaming the
money that's being put down you get some
high-quality production that I make me
go they're gonna be able to pull this
off and make it Malick to me I go yeah I
probably have the money to do it now
they have the way they do TV I think
that's that's cooler as opposed to you
know like do we need another alien movie
do we need another predator movie but
even with alien I I heard that what
they're doing is they're having fan
films be submitted something along the
lines of like people can do submit fan
films
have a lot a lot of submissions and
somehow that gets linked to canon in
some way which has which i think is cool
to have like a vote for that like that's
a different type of expansion as opposed
to damn Ridley Scott please stop making
these movies you know and it's a
different kind of fanservice - exactly
a lot more constructive than a lot of
the fanservice we see in that and that
contributes to kind of the underlying
factor of this question because you know
especially in the nostalgic time I feel
like this is a particular conundrum
because so many things get kept alive
and perpetuated simply because they were
great once we still remember that
greatness and we just don't want to let
them go and so I feel like yeah for
something like alien especially where
the past couple films haven't scratch
that itch for everybody something like
this not even past couple it's yeah it
starts to feel like we're always excited
about the prospect of alien but it
doesn't seem like they quite know what
to do yeah yeah having that was
something that - that came to me when I
saw that Star Wars fan film back in
December was I finally started to get it
cuz as much as I don't love the
bickering about Star Wars the franchise
under Disney and what they're creatives
were doing with it I saw that film and I
was like okay this is something that was
made by fans that clearly has a voice
rooted in the source material but that
has its own thing to do and say and that
could be an exciting new frontier and a
breaking down of the barrier between
people and you know movie studio yeah
yeah I mean Michael be listed Breaking
Bad here because they are making the
movie which will focus on Jesse Pinkman
and they made the Colombian remake oh
yeah that's right yes so they're doing
that and see to me I'm like okay that
that I'm not opposed to if they said
we're gonna do a Walter White movie you
know like over somehow he's not dead
then that to me would fall under the
line of you're now you're abusing this
franchise yeah unless you make it some
quiet indie movie
about him going back home and trying to
make things it's like if you had him out
drug dealing again it would just feel
like totally wrote I think what like the
the cleverness behind what Breaking Bad
has done is they did more than just one
great character you know and they had a
an end game in mind from the start from
what I've been told via now now that we
have mics I can we can to say it in the
baritone and now Marvel just like
anytime anybody says the word end game
we're all gonna think of this one I'm
trying to include an infinity war now
[Laughter]
well you see like what Marvel has done
is one of the most impressive things in
the world they've what Bond has
established over the course of many
decades they've established in one light
Lee less variation in quality and and
serial format too as opposed to you
gotta just hop into a Bond movie yeah
and I'd also say for what was this a it
was the second one Goldfinger the second
one the one that was right after dr.
know was was pretty much a direct sequel
to dr. know for the most part so yeah I
think and and then you never know like
walking dead weeds it's weird to me
what's happened with that show because
it there was a point where I'm like man
you should have ended this and then
there was like seasons just seasons were
like why is this still on the air this
is so boring I've I have never I have
never actively quit a show the way I
quit walking dead what it seemed like
for a while even the people still
watching it were we would talk about it
the way you talk about like your family
member who you have a really troubled
relationship with with your family's
exactly yeah but then now I'm hearing
after after Rick left the shows like
apparently amazing yeah finally got a
new showrunner everyone saying that I
think it's amazing
I personally still feel like mmm you see
like that it lends itself to a world of
exploration though that's the thing if
your franchise doesn't lend itself to
that kind of world
then you got to know how to end it on a
high note it's like the rocky franchise
is [ __ ] bizarre to me even though I
love those
like there's yet to be a rocky like I
don't really care for Rocky five but
even stuff like that I kind of like but
there's yet to be a rocky film where I I
hate that movie you know Creed movies
included in that franchise but that's a
franchise to where or like every single
time you're the end this fight now you
they they still deliver high-quality car
it's pretty crazy to me yeah and I feel
like that is a franchise that has the
benefit of expanding and playing out
over much time whereas nowadays the
pressure is okay we got a franchise this
immediately we got to have a new film
out in two years or something like that
whereas the Rocky films especially as
they crested and decreed and stuff like
that feel like they've kind of followed
of a natural trajectory well yeah they
found their formula and the thing is
like what's it also depends on the
standard of writing that we want from
our movies you know like when I see the
Toy Story 4 trailer it doesn't look like
a bad movie it looks like a good Pixar
movie
the thing is I'm like I've seen these
things all these things explored before
though yeah everything they're
advertising at least you know I can't
tow it is fresh here I can't talk about
the film itself to me right now toy
story 4 looks like the only best
comparison I could make off the off the
top of my head is Jason Bourne Mike is
like Jason Bourne to me was yeah this is
this is the born formula and it's did
they did it but because I've seen this
done before already there's already been
explored perfectly in a trilogy format
yeah this is kind of just okay now
inconsequential to the overall picture
yeah like none and I feel like fans have
overall responded that way to it because
there's no
talk about it born 5 you know yeah well
and they set up for a born 5 in that
movie you know oh yeah that's the thing
too now is that every movie we're in a
weird time now or it seems like
everything wants to hint at the
possibility of being a franchise in
continuing and that's something that I
do remember from being younger is that
movies would just end and then maybe you
got a sequel later and you know I feel
like we're figuring that out which is a
good thing but I think when you're
talking about when it's time to end
something versus when it's time to keep
it going I feel like you really have to
look at the spirit of it like what what
is it about what's it trying to say and
what do people like about it and you
know is that worth keeping going beyond
just the fact that it's recognizable and
profitable yeah yeah because like the
weird thing about the Prometheus concept
excited me because the thing about the
Alien franchise more than predator even
though predator does have its own
mythology and world to build off of the
thing about the Alien franchise the
movies I'm not talking about comics or
books but but the movies themselves
they're it's established a whole world
there's there's a whole universe out
there it's in the future but it's all
tied to this one nasty slimy creature
and so you can't really do much outside
of that even though you've got this
whole world's going on so Prometheus
excited me because that was yeah at the
time where you could take out the
[ __ ] xenomorph and then you could
explore like well you know if you take
out the xenomorph this is a whole world
to explore in the future yeah and then
they don't commit to that and I feel
like a lot of the times with these
franchise movies they're using alien as
an example is they're bogged down by
nostalgia factor or they're bogged down
by you know what worked in the beginning
and they're trying to include that in
some fashion especially with Prometheus
because they drove me up a wall about
that movie was that they kept I mean
Ridley Scott had this whole plan laid
out in in several interviews about all
this is going to be a bunch of movies
eventually it's going to dovetail into
but that's not our focus right now we
want to explore a whole new side of the
world and for me the prospect of that
was really cool because I was like okay
here's something that is built out of
the site of a familiar universe but that
doesn't have to rely on just that stuff
that we love yeah from that original
universe and then you go watch
Prometheus and I feel like the the alien
itself is almost a proverbial
chestburster for that movie because it's
just forced in there yeah yeah and it
kind of undoes it's like I came into
that movie because I was like oh cool
we're gonna have a mystery now and we're
going to expand this world and see some
new things and ultimately they just
didn't deliver on that principle and
then there are also franchises like die
hard where it's so heavily reliant on
Bruce Willis that's the thing that
franchise relies heavily beyond the
character of John McClane Bruce Willis
in the role of John McClane oh well yeah
cuz John John McClane is Bruce will
exactly yeah and we're at a point where
Bruce Willis where he just don't give a
[ __ ] about anything like he doesn't and
and they're still they're still making
that weird prequel die hard movie slash
sequel die hard movie word zombie you
know you see John McClane before the
events of die hard one which minimizes
the effects of die hard one when you're
just a regular cop who's in this like
crazy terrorist situation it's so to me
I'm like that's a franchise that should
just it's called die hard ha ha ha I
should die the franchise should just end
hey because your main care you you'll
never find a person another person to
replace it they the gimmick of you know
like okay first he's in the building
ya know he's on a plane you know like
that many then he get as a black friend
as much as I like live free or die hard
for its cheesiness and overall fun it's
not anywhere near on par with the first
movie and none of them have been and I
mean Tyra the Vengeance is alright
actually in my opinion yeah but I enjoy
the first three to be yeah the first
three are they're fun but but the first
one
is the great one yeah that's the great
one but then you get to part five and
I'm like guys Bruce Amell is Saint gonna
change and the other thing is there's
nothing more you can do with the
franchise there's literally nothing you
can do that wouldn't further ruin it and
and same thing with like the predator
when I think of that franchise you got a
whole world you can explore there with
the Predators the thing is is like do we
really want to see these creatures
speaking in some made-up language a
bunch of weird ass subtitles like
because they make their subtitles weird
and like what what can you really
explore there's nothing left - it's the
kind of thing where it's like you think
you have a world at your disposal or
something to explore but what you're
you're done though you're done with your
story well yeah it's like how many
different movies and stories can you
truly make out of this and on the
opposite side if you take predator as
the example is it acceptable is it what
we demand of predator each time that
it'd just be a new scenario of
characters fighting predators and it's
immediate and it's kind of like a
slasher movie and that's it or do we
want to keep it's like every predator
movie lately has had this attempt at
some kind of grand or mythology if you
look at predators it was like oh no
they're now they're coming to help us
and and it's getting more and more
convoluted and hard to stomach the more
they try and add story points to this
thing that used to just be immediate and
scary and mysterious yeah and then
sometime a lot of times the mythological
expansion ruins your franchise it ruins
your movie well I'm going to back to the
idea of prequels - it's like you know
you got this diehard prequel and I'm
sitting here thinking that it kind of
diminishes I mean every movie will exist
on its own isolated plane but after a
while especially the character like that
I'm like nobody is special all of the
time all of their life and part of the
magic of checking in with one of these
stories is this is the extraordinary
event in John McClane's life or one of a
handful but if his life is just all
extraordinary events like this mm-hmm at
a certain point yeah it just starts to
lose its effect you know it starts to
become just about okay well how
inventive were your stunts this time
yeah yeah and I I also like with
Jurassic Park that's an
the franchise where like that as cool as
the ending of Jurassic world falling
kingdom was in some ways in some ways
what they tease with that ending of
Jurassic world fallen kingdom of what
part three could be literally or even
when the franchise starts from like I
like Jurassic world one I think it's
like so silly and fun knows what it is
but you do get to the point where these
films are unlike you you're working too
much within the same box all the time
and that's why that's why I started off
this talk wits
a lot of times what gets me excited is
when you change mediums because that's
when you heat the offer room like
honestly with movies it's harder to do
the expansion because you got a like
repeat [ __ ] from the past movies in
order to satisfy and try and play to
everybody yeah exactly and and whereas
opposed to a show you can really expand
like I've always I've heard they're
finally doing this but I've said for
many years I'm like if you wanted to do
expand on the Bourne franchise you
should do a Treadstone series that I've
always said that and I think I think
recently it was announced they're going
to do that and I'm like well about time
is that's the way you continue it not
[ __ ] slap Jeremy Renner or they're in
Gulfport legacy you know or not do born
for which is exactly the you know what
we've seen a billion times already yeah
it's like what's their new to bring to
this iteration yeah I'm like dude that
some often times the best way to do it
is is change the medium and I feel like
shows have a better chance of a more
solid longevity but but shows have the
same suffer from the same problem to any
anything can go on too long and lose its
soul basically yeah this is we're all
we're all about money we're all about
greed we're all about you know just keep
milking it until okay we're officially
not gonna make more money off of this
when it's like come on guys no I know
how to end it on a note where I I don't
know what it's like it's a weird thing
it's like I get that it's a business at
the same time though you know we I guess
we need more filmmakers who are willing
to say no it's done
hey no yeah
we need more we need more Nolan's to say
like I'm not saying no one's the best
filmmaker but he's a guy who I feel like
sticks by his word uncertain things
where's look no it's done made three
film franchise with at least the Dark
Knight and people still reflect on so
its impact and power still holds up well
that's the thing too is especially with
movies I feel like finality makes
impacts bigger because if you can always
rely on something always being there
always having you a new installment
every couple of years that the tension
starts to drop and for some movies for
some franchises that is appropriate but
for others it's kind of crucial to not
lose that yeah I mean the nolan name now
is more powerful than ever because he
made a finite trilogy mm-hmm you know
what i mean yeah that's like yes he has
his inception he has interstellar but we
all really know who that I feel like if
he just did the Dark Knight trilogy and
an inception we'd have like this Nolan
brand that we have now yeah but it's but
a lot most of it is really linked to the
Dark Knight trilogy and because that was
finite you know yeah it gets to have its
own impact and you get to actually sit
and reflect on it and it gets to age
over time instead of being kind of
constantly kept alive and
recontextualized which again can work
but I don't know I feel like we value
things more from that perspective and I
feel like you can tell a much more
complete story that doesn't have to pull
punches yeah because that's the thing
about long-running franchises and we see
that like Marvel has done a great job at
this thus far at least figuring out how
we can keep a franchise ostensibly going
for 10 years and for the most part
maintaining a baseline level of quality
but well the reason the Marvel can keep
its franchise going is because of its
diversity of focusing on what characters
per movie like if it was this if they
were if they were all Iron Man movies
were to be like stop no more no more
Iron Man movie at that point like I'm
sick of Iron Man movies we've gotten
we've gone 21 Iron Man
yeah but because they're able to switch
it up with a different focus on a like
but most franchises the Marvel franchise
is unique like that and the DC franchise
is unique like that basically the comic
book franchises are unique in that
capacity because there's franchises
within franchises there yeah so you can
circumvent some of the things that maybe
are kind of the same every time yeah you
know I think that's why people are
trying to do more universe building like
the Hobbes and Shaw as part of the Fast
and the Furious universe and I'm going
to kind of sick of the word universe me
a fairy that's the other thing too is
not everything needs to be subject to
what is popular right at this minute I
feel like there needs to be a I feel
like the answer to this question
ultimately is a case-by-case one and I
feel like we need to apply that to just
the way we make movies in general
because I feel like so many things that
have the potential to be popular
automatically get kind of auditioned and
plugged into like how can we make this a
franchise and keep it running forever
and ever ever
instead of going what is this what does
it need to be and what do people want it
to be yeah you know like what they did
with Halloween recently you know just
pin making the right number two for
people is unique
simultaneously though I'm like if you
were to tell me you're making three more
of these maybe one or two more but we
don't need yeah and I feel like we might
do that you know because of the massive
hit that this last one was well that's
that's the Troublesome thing too is that
so many films come out and they're like
this is the last one and so obviously a
more people go see it that's like well
now it can't special especially with
horror though yeah yeah we made money
and and you know the horror franchises
can be a great sort of indicator for
what happens here because you have a lot
of films with an iconic first or first
couple installments that then kind of
devolve over time into a template of
sort of self referential charity and
it's hard to avoid that I feel like with
a lot of long-running franchises because
you either yeah get self-referential and
used the humor to carry you or
you just keep doing the same thing a lot
yeah or you know I wish we would embrace
a certain level of change that's why I
keep waiting for superhero movies to
really start jumping deep into the
Elseworlds type of stuff which is what
gets me excited for DC coming up because
there's so many ways to expand and do
things differently and more strangely
true and I feel like we ought to be
exploring that I guess if we want to
keep franchises going maybe going okay
we've seen it this way how do we see it
a different way because like fans
service is a huge thing now and I feel
like there are elements of that that can
be I don't love fanservice I like fan
respect it's like when there's a moment
in a movie that makes a knowing gesture
to something that is important that we
all care about I I think that's a good
thing but the way we're sort of just
like I don't know the fans love this we
have to put it in is kind of regressive
for the art form overall because I think
that there's some times when you can
change things in a way that is
ultimately good for something even
though it's not exactly what you had in
mind were wanted right off the bat you
know and I feel like we're very timid to
do that yeah yeah yeah definitely
definitely
I don't know well we probably shouldn't
probably been the biggest of hypocrites
here talking for so long keep this thing
going not knowing when to end our
podcast a prequel to this podcast right
and this thing but yeah I mean what's
your guys take on this you know what
franchises do you think should just end
right now and which ones do you think
are doing a great job keeping it going
when I was on movie fights a couple
times ago I was up against Mark and
Draco and Clarke wolf and the question
that I one of the questions we had was
which horror franchise should end and
they they said the purge and scream and
I said Texas Chainsaw and to this day I
still stand by that answer and I feel
like everyone else does yeah there's
still things you thought the perfect
prize for us I haven't brought that up
because the 10 because those movies lend
themselves to further exploration scream
show has proven it the purge world
proves
because they're reacting to things that
are happening whereas Texas Texas like
if a movies are great one-off there's a
reason why ya might get a decent sequel
out of it like I like Texas Chainsaw too
but after that you know you're like no
why did we need to do all this all right
that I'm complaining but well you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell and check out
Michael B's patreon page YouTube channel
how many one media thank you guys